[Music]
so much for coming and thanks especially
to people who are watching this live
stream I want to start today with three
vignettes overcome by enemies my gaze
darts to the air and in a rush of motion
as I fly towards my partner my heartbeat
quickens my giant continued deep Salif
blends on a platform and it falls apart
under its feet my hands shake as I
become suddenly aware of how vulnerable
I am I am startled suddenly from the
quiet rhythms of piano music and a
horse's hooves along the path by the
flapping of bird wings just ahead when
we talk about pleasures to be found in
playing video games we ought to talk
about power control agency
responsibilities and fun but these
experiences aren't covered many
sensations and although the experiences
I just described were pleasurable for me
I would not describe them as fund
exactly so what framework can we use to
talk about the ways that games can make
it pleasurable to lose control be
vulnerable and rely on others how do
games render these sensations on a
formal level and what does it mean that
we seek them out the aim of my thesis is
to use the notion of intimacy as a way
to Center these forms of pleasure and
their potential for bigger games I want
to read three contemporary Triple A
games triple A's Hollywood for games
overwatch The Last Guardian and The
Legend of Zelda a breath of the wild for
three different modes of intimacy and I
want to also consider the potential
in particular to create intimate aspects
so first I want to define what I mean by
intimacy and what I mean by dudesman
effect now really I think we all think
of intimacy as maybe describing the
usually romantic relationship between
two usually human individuals this isn't
all what I'm doing I want to think of
intimacy as a sort of aspect that
generates certain sensations and flares
so I'm going to give like a really quick
and dirty in here to have been theory to
community what I mean
Tillotson guitar you describe effect as
follows they say to their relations
composing decomposing or modifying an
individual their correspondent
intensities that affected augmenting or
diminishing its power to act so aspects
are the capacity that something has to
be a to affect and be affected by other
things effects name the valence is of
the relationships between things that
exists in the world between objects
between people and objects animals which
is sort of like an emotion or potential
energies that circulates affect theory
becomes a way to read perform and games
by understanding the potential that the
firt that certain formal elements
temporalities forms of movement have to
render serving sensations
so following offering animal and her
recent book playing with feelings video
games and effect operate says quote I
read video games not as containers of
and for effects that float around
between
and things but rather as media that have
specific affective dimensions legible
and their images algorithms
temporalities and narratives that can be
interpreted or analyzed so this formal
system allows us to examine the forces a
game world exerts a player on a formal
level as potentially containing intimate
effects now in extinct omit effects what
I need is that serving certain relations
within the space or certain forms of
movement through space become imbued
with intimacy so all kinds of relations
within the world can take on intimate
effects even when we think of intimate
early childhood and a colloquial
romantic sense the sort of intimacy of a
relationship you have what the person is
born out through other relations with
objects and gifts places or other people
so with all that what do I do next and
intimate aspect what kinds of sensations
is intimacy generate and here I want to
talk with Lauren Berlin to Nancy Youssef
I consider intimacy as a sort of
precarious synchronous orientation in
the present it's made pleasurable
pleasurable and terrifying by the
sensation of nakedness the revealing of
oneself or vulnerability some core
sensations intimacy our vulnerability
precarity a sensation of proximity of
distance and awareness of distance
intimacy is fragile
the threat of embarrassment humiliation
and disappointment always linger at its
edges sometimes intimacy becomes so
unbearable that it can be easier to end
an intimate moment than to remain
vulnerable
side of it intimacy can be cultivated
over years but it can also be unexpected
you can be thrown into intimate moments
unintentionally and intimacy has
different balances you're on a subway
alone a stranger walks in and sits
across from you you lock eyes this can
be intimate you're sitting in the
morning with an old friend having coffee
and to do lack of an in-joke that
neither of you mentioned this can also
be intimate but these intimate sees are
very different so in my thesis I want to
look at three different balances of
intimacy in the first chapter I
considered overwatch and the intimacy of
synchronicity in the second chapter I
consider the Last Guardian and the
intimacy of frustration and in my third
chapter I am going to look at the Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild and the
intimacy of overwhelmingness
and today in this presentation we're
going to talk about all three along with
I forgot you could do to make special
guests the Modlin from Zelda rent the
wild it was requested mixer did not miss
lab mates so over a watch over went to
the team beats multiplayer online
first-person shooter released by the
game company Blizzard Activision in 2016
when it was released one of the most
immediately popular and powerful
combinations was that of rocket
launching soldier Farah and an angelic
hue and mercy who these two characters
both women were immediately shipped by
fans as a romantic novel shipping is
when you support romantic pairing
characters within our or forums and
certain communities for these families
it seems like Indian synergy equates to
romantic chemistry and this is where I
sort of started this chapter and in fact
this thesis more broadly what does it
mean that families look at it this way
how does this even gain synergy between
care and mercy translate to a kind of
romantic chemistry in this chapter I
understand the flows of gameplay
involved in playing as part of Farah
Percy combination as creating intimate
modes of effective engagement so I read
the waves that you engage a partnership
on either side of it and understand how
it works together what it works well and
when it doesn't mercy is a support
character she's a doctor this means that
she heals and buffs teammates so
strengthens their abilities her
offensive abilities are extremely
limited even compared to other supports
she's not very evil to attack other
characters and harm them easily so she
focuses on helping her team she has the
unique ability he has here to fly two
teammates to escape danger to go where
she needed mercy gameplay is defined by
a precarious relationship to space she's
dependent on being able to see her
teammates or fly to them so one very
common experience for mercy players is
when your team goes when you can't see
any of them
you can't move very quickly and can
become vulnerable to enemy fire and you
die with good team support mercy it's
fast and mobile and can move all across
the map and with every team support she
becomes sluggish and fragile
so in short playing is mercy encourages
a mode of effective in
characterized by a Kent attention and
care attunement to others bees into
threats and a sort of vulnerability
implied by the process of trusting
others to be there when needed on the
other side we have Farah who is an
offensive glass cannon by what's called
a dps character so she focuses on
hurting the other team she has a unique
affinity for air support she was the
only character who can fly and float in
the air on her own she often deals heavy
damage to enemies with her rockets and
then it sets them up to the kill by
teammates on the ground so she sets up
kills but she has trouble following
through of them because they're
absolutely her rocket fires in short
playing as Farah involves making quick
and dangerous plays but also having a
certain amount of caution to pull back
from engagements before he's killed
there's a sense of vulnerability to the
team and reliance on the team that
stands in contrast with other offensive
characters like the soldier 76 or Reaper
who can make kills more independent even
if Aaron so I traced out a few sort of
forms of effective risk the human
engagement with mercy and when they play
together these risks are mitigated in
the air Farah makes a good escape for
mercy she's almost always visible so
it's easy for mercy to fly to her if she
gets overrun matey by opponents and
Farrell also provides a vantage point
that gives mercy a visibility over the
rest of the team so she can fly back to
the rest of the team this creates a sort
of anchoring point where mercy might go
elsewhere but she always comes
era mercy on her part provides healing
and buffing for Paris and American
sustained engagements and follow-through
and kills Farrah becomes more secure
powerful and reliable and mercy becomes
more mobile and as a safe place to go
this creates a sort of flow of game they
were effective mercy Farah players push
together
retreat together and regroup together it
becomes a sort of synchronous flow of
gameplay that encourages both players to
rely heavily on each other and
anticipate and nullify threats to one
another but the combination is always
precarious Farah and mercy are always in
danger of falling out of step without
Farah visible and available to her mercy
becomes confined to the ground and
easily isolated for her teammates and
without mercy healing her Tamara becomes
vulnerable to enemy kills and unable to
sustain engagements as effectively even
when they weren't well on a team
together they become isolated from the
rest of their team when they move
effectively which can cause a lot of
frustration on the part of the other
four players who play on the team and
even when they're together their
movements in the air are sheepy and of
the precarious and always in theater
falling to the ground
the disorienting flight patterns and
fragile dependencies of the fairy mercy
combination often lead not to success
worried into pleasure but to failure
asynchronous movement and frustration
and this is what I think of as the
intimacy of synchronicity sort of a
present temporality oriented form of
flowing synchronously with another body
and space it's always in danger of
falling out of step it's easy to think
of it to the sea it's a positive aspect
you know we think of romance safety and
comfort
we use that term but precarity and the
negative aspects of vulnerability are
crucial to intimacy as well and this is
what I explore in my second chapter so
in overwatch the negative sensations are
always sort of lingering at the edges
but what happens to me tendencies define
my negative sensations not bites our
free-flowing precarious synchrony but by
frustration of sluggishness and
incapacity The Last Guardian is a
single-player adventure game released in
2016 that follows the relationship
between an unnamed
young boy busy up there in a giant
Griffin like creature called Treecko the
player controls the boy in must
negotiate with Treecko who has fears
needs once and who doesn't always listen
or follow directions as they navigate
through the highly vertical ruins of
some ancient technologically advanced
civilization the game was praised
especially for the sort of complex
relationship be created between the boy
and Treecko almost entirely through in
play as opposed to dialogue but some
criticized how treecko's in full orders
one polygon reviewer wrote if the main
character annoys because he moves
exactly as you'd expect a little boy too
then the Treecko annoys because it acts
exactly as an expected cat act it makes
for a realistic depiction of my favorite
house pet but it's terrible game I think
there's a sort of broader tension here
with the idea of losing control and
games with having to wait and be patient
and accommodating and I think that this
is especially complicated because we're
talking about a human
relationship here so we need to unpack
this what is intimate what's revealed
about intimacy by a frustrating
encounter with an animal defined by
helplessness and weeding so I read The
Last Guardian for an intimacy defines my
frustration and slowness and the
inability to move properly The Last
Guardian understands to conceal all
weeks frustrating never quite the
creating are powerful as a negotiation
that's never quite resolved but perhaps
the negotiation itself is pleasurable so
the two bodies that move through space
together are both defined by their
inability to do things quite right the
boy has a tremendously hard time
affecting the world around him he's
always stumbling falling over tripping
over himself he has to pull switches and
he has to put his whole body into it it
takes him a full second to do so he's
really quite bad at doing those things
even a slave sort of junk public fall
over onto its face meanwhile wearing if
the boy is tremendously sort of
sensitive to the world and can't affect
it at all Treecko is defined by the way
that it always affects the world no
matter what it does
Treecko certain barrels through the
space knocking things over frequently
destroying entire statements of the
ruins so neither of them quite fit
through the space Treecko is too big it
always sort of knocks things over and
ruins everything well the boy struggles
to get to high places climb up stairs
and make it across sir these long gaps
now this is a linear game which means
that you can't explore the world too
much there's always only one intuitive
direction you can go but the way this
linearity is experienced through the
design of the space is such that you
think it's linear because of the limited
ways that Treecko and the boy can move
through it so there's always only one
way you can fit through this space it's
not that the space is sort of a single
lane that you
that there's other entrances you see
other places where you could go if only
you could fit that you can't the result
of this is a sense of desperation and
hyper awareness of the bodies of the boy
and Treecko so players are always need
to ask where can I go where can I fit
but the massive scale of the space is
sort of intense verticality of it also
means that closing the distance is given
a particular effective weight so this is
fun this gift of MIDI one of my favorite
moments in the game when the boy has to
jump across a great chasm to get to
Treecko and this happens several times
as her temporal structure where time
slows down as the boy jumps you go to
slow motion sort of whooshing some the
you here volunteer theater becomes
almost mechanical sounding and then you
just begin to get a sense of how far you
will fall and where you will land on the
ground like hundreds of feet down before
treecko's head appears when its tail
appears you grab it it brought to you
time returns to normal and everything
becomes quiet as you are lifted to a
safe space this entire scene the
architecture of the space the structure
of time is named around sort of the
moment of extended precarity a moment
that emphasizes the boys inability to
cross the gap of his bone so you might
be sort of bloated intense precarious
movements but then you have these long
stretches of waiting this is a really
popular gift that was circulated around
the time the game came out the boy as
you come in
Rico which are entirely sort of gestural
but the commands aren't always
consistent as to what they mean or is to
have treatment interprets them and so
the result is that and I did this in my
own weekly experience you sort of cycle
through commands in dance in different
ways trying to get treatment you end up
feeling a little crazy and sometimes you
know you really goes nobody commands he
just doesn't understand them sometimes
he doesn't listen sometimes sometimes it
doesn't care and sometimes he just wants
to give you something else it becomes
almost sort of calm about sometimes
about myself laughing a lot and serve at
the end of these long frustrating
periods of weeding there's often just
more frustration to get over the chasm
tricot finally does but you wanted to
and then he gets home Rudy lies down you
have to wait another 10 minutes so maybe
start to structures and frustration in
Alaska our day and there's waiting and
then there's the awaited thing happening
and both of these things are frustrating
in their own ways so what about intimacy
we've we've talked about frustration a
lot and we've seen intimacy at the
margins so the bloated precarious which
I think both it was sort of reminiscent
of chapter one right but in order to
understand the role of intimacy and
frustration here we have to understand
that the way the game constantly insists
on the subjectivity of Treecko there's
so many moments in this game when you
stand in front of the Treecko Treecko
sits down and looks at you and
everything is still and you just look at
each other or you have to go and Kiko
responds to you being petted
there's a way that this sort of process
of looking
create that sort of connection I want to
describe one moment in particular
there's a moment when violent forces in
the game mean that the boy is knocked
out and he can't wake up now drove the
game you many times have to wake up the
boy with controls in your controller but
this time no matter what you do the boy
won't wake up and tricot takes the boy's
body nudges him takes him into the
sunlight touches him again
it's a almost excruciating 1 minute 30
second long sequence and no matter what
you order to go do the boy will wake up
until finally at the end of the sequence
tree go put some water and he awakes in
my only play experience I found this
moment deeply upsetting after playing
for hours and finding only frustration
and the boys limited capacity to this
new frustration of suddenly being unable
to move at all expanded into a profound
vulnerability that I experienced it once
from my own subject position from the
boys and from treecko's in light of
treecko's and at the same time my own
quiet just desperate response to the
boys unconsciousness
I found an intimacy in our collective
and capacities so I think here Donna
Haraway
it talks about staying with the trouble
of climate change and environmental
destruction in certain contemporary
precarious times personally not solution
but the way that she contends with the
trouble is to stay with it in quote a
thick present not as a vanishing pivot
between awful or endemic pasts and
apocalyptic or South Pacific futures but
as more of mortal critters entwined in
myriad unfinished configurations of
places times matters and innings for
Haraway species interdependence
name of the world in game on earth and
that game must be one of response and
respect that is the play of companion
species learning to pay attention so
with these terms
stay with the trouble and companion
species Paraguay treats as a model of
being with and becoming with that is
marked by a temporalities stubbornly and
decisively oriented and a present that's
thick slow difficult and even painful
which i think is reminiscent of the
intimacy of frustration I think it's in
the too long too tall sometimes
unbearable durations of waiting and
experiences of inability that make up
the last garden where moments but
profound no durability and intimacy can
be found so coming from here my question
was what other intimacy's might result
from gains that force their players to
be within perfection as vulnerable and
it's intolerable as I can be and that
brought me to the Legend of Zelda rather
the quiet now techne buddy who is even
slightly familiar with this game - sort
of problems make themselves immediately
clear first is that the intimacy event
of the wild isn't anchored to another
individual in overwatch we talked about
intimacy between fara and mercy two
characters each play fights human
players and in the Last Guardian we talk
about the intimacy between a human and
an animal the intimacy of enter the wild
is an intimacy distributed across space
it's not connected to another individual
body so how do you need for that and
second rather the wild is a huge game
you can easily play for 200 hours and
not have done everything in this game I
could break entire essays about animal
photography about cooking in this game
which are tiny minigames that you really
have to participate in
game so it's overwhelming even to think
of the writing of this game which meant
that I had two sets of questions going
forward first what happens to be when it
becomes distributed across States in
this way and second what's intimate
about being overwhelmed what does it
mean to be overwhelmed and what does it
mean that my critical engagement in the
game is also overwhelming I wanted to
find overall in this year I make up over
a momentous as a series of encounters
that not individually but an aggregate
and their multiplicity create a sense of
accumulating tension anxiety and
smallness overwhelmingness can dissipate
for a time for example any moment of
calm and it can be evaded or postponed
but it can't be fully resolved but it
has to be contended with until it
subsides what I think of / / well - in
terms of effect I may describe it as an
overabundance of
effects so an overabundance of ways to
affect in being effective and also a
kind of encounter with how many things
you can do how many things can be done
to you and I think it's sort of two
forms of overwhelming
first thing they've ever Isaac tension
know anybody who's played this game this
is a pretty funny gift Claudia in this
gift like his trying to write a pot lid
down a hill the pot leg breaks he falls
rolls over and then slowly dies game
over
this is sort of not any one thing that's
a problem but it's the series of things
in anger again that sort of accumulate
to become across the rolling down the
hill the public breaking the weird
decision to provide a pot lid down hell
in the first place I experienced
something rather similar in terms of
combat when I played in front of the
while I'll describe it briefly walking
through a cave I see a few lightning
bats as you do in this game back to meet
with a magical power of lightning so I
take away bow and arrow I kill a couple
but I run out of arrows so exciting to
switch to a spear which is a long weapon
that won't let me kill the bats and get
through the cave safely but as I'm
switching to the spear and evening it
one sort of angles around he gets me in
the side shocking me when you're shot by
lightning you drop whatever you're
holding so I dropped the sphere the
sphere moves down the hill now I'm one
less a sphere I grab a sword but the
sword is shorter and I'm not used to the
range of the sword which means that
another bat gets when he shocks me I
drop the sword the sword also rolls down
to Tilson I don't know how many weapons
I have left now
think it's a torch in the leaf my health
is low my healing supplies are limited I
decide to book it out of there which
means that I sprint and run but when you
sprint in this game you use up stamina
and so I'm running I run out of stamina
and I run right into another nest of
monsters and you know what happened next
I die this is pretty typical it's not
one thing in these certain situations
but in the wild but it's the way that
these situations get more and more
perfect or simply complicated it's the
sort of problems in aggregate that
become we have to deal with and this is
also an issue that I think of with a
number of things you can do with the
world and how you sort of describe your
engagement with the world when I talk to
my friends about this game in every
converting the chapter it was really
interesting to me that so many of them
when they were asked to describe what
they liked about this game described all
the individual things you can do they
would say oh whoa I like you know even
you can cook and stuff and like there's
all these different fruits and look at
the animals but as they described word
more things they became more and more
them to explain exactly what in total
made them like the game other than
through all of these sort of little
individual stories and moments and this
sort of exerts a force during the
gameplay as well
you become surprised suddenly in a
lightning storm as you realize that the
metallic items equipped on your back
conduct electricity and even vulnerable
to being struck by lightning lightning
has been a real problem for me this game
or suddenly you realize that enemies can
interact with each other or join an
enemy can throw a smaller enemy of you
it's sort of constantly surprise
process of discovering the things can
interactive way that you didn't expect I
think this is similar to the intimacy of
frustration and then to become
increasingly aware the capacities of
your body but unlike the sort of
constant frustrations and extended
waiting periods of the Gardea this is a
sort of slowly accumulating tension that
is either dissipated or sort of boils
over the second structure of being
overwhelmed I think that was kind of
interrupted rhythm I described this at
the beginning of this presentation I'm
going to describe it again when link
rides for long enough on his horse a
sort of piano music starts to play in
the background that's reminiscent to be
galloping rhythm the horse moves
automatically along the path which means
you don't need to control it with your
controller for it to know when to turn
and Lincoln the player sort of lulls
into an age where you feel certain
rhythms of the horse galloping the
sounds and you look at the land as it
sort of passes by you but all of a
sudden then the rhythm is disrupted
there are birds that are always sitting
on the path that fly waves suddenly in
front of you startling you monsters can
cross the road can attack you can knock
you off your horse and someone under the
path gives way very suddenly without
warning to a cliff as soon as the rhythm
is of course rider in a path come into
harmony they're lost and link has to
find his way back to the path and to the
loss rhythm so Lynx rhythms are sort of
overwhelmed by these constant smaller
disruptions I think if this is
reminiscent of the intimacy of
synchronicity in that these rhythms are
these are rhythms there's who always
under threat but these were those rather
than being created through interactions
with another individual are created
three interactions with space its
disrupted not only by not just by
calling it up step but by sort of
geographic features in a way the world
record the wildly reads attempts to fall
into rhythm with it
but creating your own rhythms also
becomes a way of
and this is where I'm gonna finally talk
about cooking so the process of cooking
teks have benefited in this game you go
into your inventory and pull items you
throw them into a cooking pot outside of
the inventory a little with them plays
as a link excitedly watches the cook and
then at the end you get you get the food
it sort of pops out link it's very happy
during this sequence you can't do
anything other than sort of angle the
camera in different ways to sort of get
a sense of the food or gonna look at
like space I repeated this one-minute
loop probably about 20 times in a signal
to our play session there's so much to
do with its key there's so many places
you can explore but I found myself doing
the same things over and over and try
them again these are different smaller
configurations each time see if I can
get the best angle and length space I
collecting things and other rhythm as
you run around and you press a pocket to
pick up items from the ground and a sort
of satisfying Saturday plays they do
over and over and over again animal
photography it's the same sort of
patterns rhythms of action I became
lulled into the rhythmic movements and
slight variations of each loop
so what's intimate here is it being
overwhelmed there is sort of rhythms
that you create in order content with a
sort of overwhelming quality of
everything you can do and I think it's
both I think that intimacy is working on
two levels here on the one level the
player is made constantly aware
painfully of their vulnerability through
these sort of building tensions and
rising
cassadee's and also through sudden
unexpected disruptions but at the same
time the player learns to contend with
its vulnerability to stay with to make
revans that make it bearable there's an
intimacy here in being made painfully
aware of your or her abilities to space
to a world in orienting yourself within
than these vulnerabilities and in
finding a way to contain them so there
are two things that I've learned through
my travels and intimate worlds but I'd
like to conclude with today first I
think that video games have a unique
capacity to generate intimate effects
the relationships with space that I
described the frustrations and
familiarities of bodily and capacities
synchronous actions with others lyrics
these are experiences that video games
have the unique capacity to generate
centering the sort of intimate effects
of these games create space for
different players and different
pleasures and sent during the formal
ways these intimacy's are created
hopefully draws attention to the as yet
unrealized potential of games to create
intimate effects second I believe that
intimacy is a way to contend with
precarity
so I use precarity through this thesis
and the term and I've used it with
attention to the political context of
the word not only the neoliberal
conditions of precarious labor in which
we find ourselves but also more broadly
a sort of contemporary affective
precarity as Lauren forelimbs and Katie
Stewart Department I think that one
thing that's come up for me throughout
this business has been how do you
contend with this sort of total
uncertainty and what does it mean to
defendant total uncertainty and here I
want to turn to n and sing in her book
the mushroom at the end of the world she
describes precarity as life without the
promise of stability as the condition of
trouble without end but also as a state
of acknowledgement of our vulnerability
to others seeing tracks the Commerce and
ecology of matsutake mushrooms in order
to conceive of a
path towards collaborative survival in
precarious times
Fritzing looking at precarity through
the case of the matsutake mushroom makes
it evidence that indeterminacy also
makes life possible Donna Haraway also
alludes to this and stay with the
trouble for haraway staying with the
trouble requires making odd kin that is
we required each other in unexpected
combinations and collaborations in hot
compost piles we become with each other
or not at all
I think that's playing with and working
through intimate effects is a way that
we can learn to contend with
vulnerability to stay with the trouble
of precarity to try and find the kind of
indeterminacy that affords new
possibilities there are certain times
[Applause]
so so going back to your chapter on
overwatch when you were talking about a
was a intimate relationship that was
read that way because of an occult
compatibility so what is your
understanding of other popular sort of
ships of characters who either are like
who don't have not same kind of Apple
compatibility especially when they're
like that much be opposed yeah yeah
maybe I think that you know the way of
fans is the people share everything
so there are ships for almost every
character in overwatch in those 27
heroes that's a lot of combination but
Farah and mercy have always been with
the most popular ships and I think that
it is because of it sort of
synchronicity in a way that they are
able to be together
sort of but there's other combinations -
I think that one that's really
interesting to me is again can zenyatta
unlike vertices and evidence he's of
support but he also is stationary and he
sort of gives orbs to his teammates and
then they can go away so there's a kind
of anchoring we're getting G because
this were a very cool file here at
Lulu's across the back getting people
would soar to the ninja where he sort of
comes back to the data gets an orb
there's also over the popular shift
between trig certain Widowmaker
Widowmaker is a night bird creature is a
sort of flanking hero and there's a
really interesting way that there they
sort of always dramatic show their note
when they're on opposite teams but it
was always trying to sneak a headshot
new traits original cover whereas tracer
is trying to sort of sneak up on
Widowmaker and and get the drop on her
and there's a way that sort of
cat-and-mouse game becomes a kind of
contingency as well a binding can be
really interesting to write about all
the different ships overwatch actually
yeah that's really interesting I think
sure yeah so the question was how does
the sort of structure of
overwhelmingness change when you
accumulate more items and sort of
weapons to make a to become more
powerful
yeah that's a really good question and I
think that there's a different kind of
overall message that comes from having
so many items to be things that you can
do right there's so many different
costumes that you can use those are
different ways to do different things in
the game there's so many weapons that
you encounter the game that you have to
sort of throw out other weapons you
don't really have enough space in your
inventory to contain all the things that
you could have and it's almost like as
the game progresses there's so much so
many things to do in so little time that
I think it becomes a different sort of
form of overall business but then
there's always the sort of potential
that I think goes from the central
component to being more at the edges of
still being overwhelmed I had
experiences in May of where even though
I had maybe 10 hearts and very good
armor I would still get me shot down in
extremely bad situations right like I
could find myself in a situation that
would just become even too bad for me
and in those situations it's almost even
more overwhelming because even though
you've got all this preparation because
it quite work out for you so that's
actually a really interesting question
that I that I would like to think about
where the idea of sort of this
progression Lisa
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so the question was
talking about sort of motion and scale
as sort of overarching themes and my
thesis and if I'd consider that in
relation to precarity yes I think it is
it's something that I talk a lot more
about the thesis thinking about sort of
focused sick of these forms of movement
and also of temporality I think that I
mean aspect Theory likes to focus on
these things in general but I think
especially in games where sort of
experiences of motion and temporality
are the ways that you play the game in
some sense I've also been reading a lot
Tristan whistled has done some really
interesting work on verticality and sort
of these increase in certain vertical
spaces in contemporary cinema and
blockbuster cinema as being sort of
connected to experiences of like like
mobility economic mobility or
socio-economic mobility so that's
something that that I've been thinking
about a lot yes
yeah yeah I think it's no I mean I think
that companions are really really
interesting figures because it once they
sort of I think historically have served
as the sort of space of interesting
representations whether of women or of
non-human characters but on the other
hand that sort of becomes problematic
think that the companion characters are
there to support you and help you and
sometimes named you and they're sort of
frustrating generally is that companion
characters get talked about and it seems
like a way that developers have dealt
with that is to make the characters
never get in a way right so it's like
well at least this you know this woman
might be like bothering you and egging
you but at least she doesn't get hard so
you don't have to protect her she can
like hide on her own and I think it's a
real problem
in game dev I actually think there were
the most poignant things about the Last
Guardian is that Treecko gets in the way
there's times when Treecko steps on your
knocks you over or doesn't position
itself properly so you try to reach air
to catch it and instead again that sort
of bloated moment I described you fall
yeah and I think it's obviously
frustrating for a lot of players but I
think we need intimacy in that it's sort
of making you have to deal with
something else and accompany something
else I think that there's a sort of
practice and games and game doubt of the
mentality that you should always have
control of the flow of things and you
should always have control and
we need to do a better job that's really
a Tuesday
yes so the question was sort of how do
we keep precarity given the kind of sort
of teleological like I said we need
States or any states of games I think
that there's different ways that games
do it I mean with over watching never
ends you just play on their games and
sort of flows that you get into or get
out of are always for continues that's
what another way the last Guardium
doesn't is you don't really have
power-ups in that game the only
power-ups you have our maybe being able
to sort of communicate a little better
with Treecko but you can actually do
that stuff from the beginning it's never
sort of the you dino level and gain
arbor in mozilla i think that the way
that they do it is with world that is
always extremely dangerous in a world in
which it continues to be interesting to
try things afternoon punky in i know a
lot of people who played this game who
defeating Ganon became like a chore but
they waited to do or that they've got
over with
you get back to like cooking and taking
pictures of birds yeah and so I think
that I mean I think that there that
maybe we also need to move beyond the
kind of like progression who moving
upwards progression towards this and
they were you feel very powerful maybe
that's a way that we sort of stay with
precarity I think all my themes however
the interesting space for this but
generally I look forward to seeing what
like developers
[Music]
[Applause]